hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
today is the q a video for idea number
what is it
emergence 21 idea number 21 was
emergence
and i have to confess there's going to
be a tiny little bit of a problem or
there was a tiny bit of a problem today
um
i usually generate questions for the q a
videos from
questions that are asked on the youtube
uh site but also
and a lot of them are actually from my
actual website preposterousuniverse.
where on the blog i put up a separate
little blog post for every
biggest ideas video and i didn't realize
this but apparently the most recent
wordpress upgrade
broke the blog so it's still there
and you can go in and you can leave a
comment but the comments don't show up
so to any of you out there who have left
comments i know what they are they're in
the database and they will eventually
appear on the website
but i think a lot of people weren't
leaving comments because comments
weren't appearing so
we got fewer questions than usual and
the questions we did get you know there
were a lot of them
about the emergence of space-time which
i know is uh
not strictly in the venue of what we're
talking about here the biggest ideas
videos because i'm trying to stick to
things that we basically understand
right like ideas we know to be true
when it comes to emergence of space time
we don't really know we're talking about
we're very speculative we have ideas
they're potentially good ideas maybe
great ideas
but they could be also completely wrong
and we're not about possibly completely
wrong ideas here at the biggest idea
series but
it's the q a video and you know i lost a
lot of the questions i might have been
asked and number three
this is what i'm working on right now as
a scientist so
i'm just going to do a little
self-indulgent thing during this q a
video and basically use it to give a
little
introduction or discussion to the work i
am currently personally doing
on the emergence of space-time and i say
that not because my work is better than
any other people's but because i know it
and i want to emphasize that there are a
lot of other approaches out there so my
approach or the approach i'm going to
talk about
here is certainly not the only one or
the most popular one or even the best
but it is one i know and like the best
so it's one i'm gonna talk about there
you go
uh so the emergence of space-time is
what we're gonna talk about
and something that needs to be
emphasized here
is that we talked back
in the video we had a whole video on the
biggest idea of space time itself
and separately we had an idea on
emergence so this is a natural topic
but the thing that we emphasized was
that even though we had
previously separate ideas of space and
time
einstein came and minkowski and they you
know
brought them together into one
four-dimensional space-time so we talked
about the emergence of space-time but
in fact in practice the emergence of
space
and the emergence of time seem to be
potentially two very different things
it's possible that space is fundamental
but time is not time is fundamental but
space is not or both are not fundamental
and therefore emergent all these are
possible
so mostly i'll be talking about the
emergence of space and taking time is
fundamental but we'll see where we go
we'll try to get to time
and the context in which i want to talk
about this you know we talked about
quantum mechanics and so when we say
emergence in this sense
it's from quantum mechanics you know
emergence itself need not be
from quantum to classical there's all
sorts of different kinds of emergence
but space-time is already there
classically there's nothing for it to
emerge from so
what we mean generally by the emergence
of space-time is from quantum mechanics
so the first thing we need to do is to
pick
quantum mechanics right we talked about
in the quantum mechanics idea video
about how you know there's different
approaches to quantum mechanics there's
evaredian or many worlds there's pilot
wave or hidden variables there's
spontaneous collapse epistemic
approaches on and on
so you need to pick a particular way of
going about you know
i'm going to pick average in many worlds
quantum mechanics but in particular
i'm going to pick what uh ashmit singh
who used to be a
student at caltech now as a postdoc we
have dubbed
mad dog everettianism
so this is
the ultimate form of everettianism the
furthest you can go remember one of the
selling points
of everybody in quantum mechanics is you
just have a wave function
it's in hilbert space it evolves
according to the schrodinger equation
okay
so that's great that's very lean and
mean ontologically but
the words wave function there are doing
a lot of work you know the wave function
is a vector
in hilbert space but when you actually
write down a wave function
you write it down as you know a function
of a set of variables like the positions
of particles or
something like that so in mad dog
everettianism
you take seriously the idea that the
wave function is a vector of hilbert
space
but you don't say that it's a function
of certain variables
that's just a way of representing the
wave function in certain contexts that
might not work in other contexts and
it's completely non-unique so i'll talk
about that in a second but
what we mean here by mad dog aboriginism
is simply the idea that
there is a quantum state a wave function
a state vector whatever you want to call
it
it is an element of hilbert space curly
h
and it evolves uh under the schrodinger
equation so that means that there's a
hamiltonian
operator that acts on the wave function
and that is equal to i
times the derivative d by dt of the wave
function
so the hamiltonian is the thing that
asks the question how much energy
is there in this wave function and the
schrodinger equation
says the more energy there is the faster
the wave function evolves
typically the wave function is going to
be a superposition of many different
energies so different parts of it will
evolve at different rates that's why the
universe is an interesting place okay
and that's it so this is the claim of
mad dog ever readiness there's no
extra stuff no extra baggage attached to
what kind of wave function we have
it's just a vector in hilbert's space if
you say well
i think that we are a set of quantum
fields living in a three-dimensional
space evolving with time well
okay the mad dog ever ready in
philosophy says you have to derive that
you have to show how all that stuff
emerges okay so this is a very
natural setting to talk about the
emergence of space time we have nothing
to start with
but a wave function and a hamiltonian
how can we possibly you know the
question goes
emerge things from there so just to
drive that home
the more conventional thing to do
would be to say that the wave function
is a function right it's a map
from let's say some configuration of
stuff
configuration particles or fields or
what have you to the complex numbers
okay so this might be for example
the positions of some particles oops x
1 x 2 dot
many little x's uh or in a different
theory it could be a set of fields
phi 1 as a function of x phi 2
as a function of x etc that would be a
field theory
so there's different kinds of
configuration spaces and you get
functions of all of them that are
complex valued and those are a way of
making your hilbert space vectors and
then you can add them together etc
but it's immediately a little suspicious
when you
treat this kind of idea too seriously
when it comes to the wave function i
mean
of course you can write the wave
function as a function of some positions
if that's the system you're thinking
about
but you could you know you could also
take psi as a function of x1 i'm going
to forget the vector signs just for
complicity
x2 etc and you can switch from position
space to momentum space
right we talked about that the fourier
transform idea
instead of giving you the wave function
at every location of all the different
particles
we give you the wave function at every
momentum of the different particles
and it's exactly the same information
it's re so you don't give them both
that will be redundant you can go back
and forth there's a well-defined
computation you do
starting with the wave function and
position space to get
the wave function in momentum space p1
p2 etc okay so
you can ask yourself well which of these
the position space or the
momentum space representation of the
wave function is more important
is more fundamental is real in some
sense
and there's nothing in the mathematics
nothing whatsoever that distinguishes
them
at the level of importance or
fundamentality right
so that's why you might be led to this
mad dog approach
which says what matters is the vector in
hilbert space
the abstract notion of the quantum state
not some particular representation of it
in position or momentum or anything like
that
so we want to do is you know this the
task is
from this information there's a hilbert
space there's a vector in it there's a
hamiltonian that drives the schroedinger
equation
how does everything emerge how does the
world
emerge so nowhere in here
is anything like space particles
fields gauging variants right none of
those
things are in this setup they have to
emerge out of there somehow
so how do you actually do that um well
what information do you have to work
with
is one question so uh the information
you have
the first thing you have is hilbert
space so you have
hilverspace sadly is very boring it's a
vector space it's a complex value vector
space and you can take the dot product
between different vectors
that's it there's some technical
complications for infinite dimensional
ones but that's basically it okay
complex valued vector space with a dot
product
all complex values vector spaces with a
dot product
are isomorphic to each other there's no
difference between any of them
as long as they have the same
dimensionality so the dimensionality
little d of hilbert space is one piece
of information
that you have that's a good starting
point to work with
and that's really the only information
you have about helper space that's all
you need to define it it's
the hamiltonian that is going to give
you most of the information that we care
about here
so for the hamiltonian usually
you know the hamiltonian operator
is something like you know for a single
particle you would write 1 over 2m
times the momentum squared plus some
potential energy
as a function of the position squared
something like that okay
and you say well that's the hamiltonian
but that way of writing the hamiltonian
is not compatible with the mad dog
philosophy
because this assumes there's something
called momentum and something called
position
where did you get that from right that's
cheating as a mad doggie and everettian
all you have is a vector in hilbert's
space you don't have positions in
momentum yet
so how are you going to get that uh
instead what you have
are energy eigenstates
so instead of the usual story
we're going to look at energy
eigenstates which is
a way of saying there are certain
special states in hilbert space
once you have a hamiltonian okay so
hoverspace by
itself bunch of vectors they're all
created equal none of them is any better
than any others but now you say okay the
hamiltonian
that picks out certain states as special
and the way they're special is
uh there's a set of them call them
phi sub n okay and
n is going to go from one
up to d there's going to be the same
number of states as there are dimensions
of hilbert space in fact they will end
up being a basis for this vector space
so you can construct any other
vector in hilbert space by taking a
linear combination of these
special basis states and their
definition of them is they satisfy an
equation that when you take the
hamiltonian
and you act it on these states not just
the arbitrary wave function of the
universe but these particular states
a wonderful thing happens where the
answer
does not change with time it is just
given by
some number called the energy times the
state itself
so usually when you take a vector in
hilbert's face and you act the
hamiltonian on it you get a different
vector
in hilbert's space okay this is saying
that there are certain states when you
act the hamiltonian on them
they don't change they might expand or
contract but they don't move to another
state
it's like this you know think about
rotating things
and visual aid time again rotating
things in three dimensions right
imagine all the different ways i can
rotate but imagine just one kind of
rotation at a time
if i have like a sphere any rotation i
do on that sphere
is going to leave some point on the
sphere one pole and the opposite pole
invariant unchanging there's no one
simple rotation i can do on the sphere
that moves every point i can you know
combine different rotations to do that
but one small infinitesimal rotation at
a time will always leave
some points invariant those are the
eigen states
of that rotation those are the vectors
that are not
changed in their orientation so that's
what the energy eigenstates are given
the hamiltonian these are the states
that
when you act a hamiltonian on them they
just get bigger or smaller that's
multiplying by this number en
but they don't change where they're
pointing so these numbers are called the
eigenvalues or the energy eigenvalues
you can hear ariel meeping in the
background maybe i think she doesn't
like it when i do these uh
these q a videos um because saturday you
know she thinks i should be playing with
the kitties
um good but so this is saying that just
by saying that there is a hamiltonian
which you need to do
otherwise you have not defined a
physical theory some
states are special some states are
states of definite energy they're not
combinations
the energy eigenvalue is the energy of
the state that's what we mean
a typical state that you might imagine
is not an energy eigenstate it's a
combination of many states and otherwise
otherwise it wouldn't change you notice
that
uh this this state just doesn't actually
change its form when the hamiltonian
acts on it so it doesn't evolve over
time in any non-trivial way
anyway okay so the data that we have
the information that the theory is
giving us
are these energy eigenvalues en
for n goes from one to the
dimensionality of the state
of the hilbert space and maybe also
maybe okay
we'll allow ourselves to look at a
particular
state like maybe you say well i'm going
to imagine
that i'm following the evolution of the
universe and the wave function in the
universe starts in a particular state
and then it evolves
that's a natural thing to say okay so we
can write
phi initial let's say psi initial
this is the greek letter psi this these
energy eigenstates i'm writing as the
greek letter phi i can write phi
initial as a sum over values
of indices n of some constants
called amplitudes right psi n times phi
n so because the phi ends the energy
eigenstates
are a basis for hilbert space i can
write any
uh vector as the sum of them so very
very schematically here's hilbert space
it's a vector space this is a
two-dimensional vector space okay
uh here is some eigen
energy eigenstate psi one here's another
energy eigenstate
ah sorry phi one this is phi two
and any other state psi i can write as a
appropriate linear combination of those
that's what's going on here pictorially
okay
so what we are able to ask ourselves is
given so therefore we're given also
these initial states
eigen amplitudes psi n
so we get we are given not that much
information we're given
d the dimensionality of the space we're
given the energy eigenvalues
en and we're given maybe some state
i'm not actually going to use the state
explicitly but
in principle we're allowed to do that
where it's not cheating to help
ourselves to that information
maybe it's important for certain
questions okay and from this set of data
right just a list of numbers
a list of you know one number d d
num d real numbers e n and d complex
numbers psi
n um you're gonna say oh someone's gonna
hand you then you're gonna go oh yes
that is a three-dimensional space with
um a gauge group
su-3 su 2 cross 1 quantum field theories
obeying laurence and varian equations
motion you know stuff like that you're
going to say all that you're going to
derive that
from these numbers that sounds hard and
it is hard we have no idea how to do it
but we're sort of clawing our way
toward there very very gradually so how
do we do it
um how do we reconstruct the world
let's start with
space you know you've got to start
somewhere so what we're going to say is
given these pieces of data this
information about our theory
what kind of space are we going to say
could potentially emerge
from it right and the game we're going
to play is
we know a lot of the answer we know in
other words we know what kind of thing
we
want to have emerge from our
more fundamental quantum mechanical
theory
we don't know so what we're going to be
asking is
two questions number one what are the
requirements on the hamiltonian
to allow anything to emerge that we want
and number two
how do we know when you have that
hamiltonian what it is that actually
does emerge
what we're not asking ourselves is why
does the hamiltonian take that
form okay so in the mad dog approach
the theory of everything is just a
hilbert space and hamiltonian
which means a list of a number of energy
eigenvalues that's it that's the entire
theory of everything
okay any talk you want to do of strings
or loops or
causal chains or whatever that's
supposed to emerge
from all this we're starting with bare
bones quantum mechanics
and so uh what the first thing to do is
to say well
there is space we know there is space in
the real world so
what are the properties this hamiltonian
and eigenvalues need to have
for space to emerge we're not asking why
the hamiltonian has those properties
some hamiltonians will allow space to
emerge some will not
that's above our pay grade for today's
uh video
so let's start with space what do we
know about space well there's instantly
a worry
that when we know that we have quantum
field theory right in our usual way of
talking about the best current theory of
nature quantum field theory
we made a big deal out of explaining
that there are an infinite number
of degrees of freedom so there you would
imagine that the dimensionality of
hilbert space
is infinite and maybe it is it's
absolutely possible
to mention the hyperspace is infinite
but it raises all sorts of problems for
this program like it's very very hard to
get off the ground when
i mean roughly speaking every energy
eigenvalue exists
the only thing you're talking about is
the relative frequency of different
energy eigenvalues and that gets very
very subtle and complicated and hard
but there's good news the good news is
that
practically speaking there are very good
reasons to believe that the
dimensionality of hilbert space in our
observable universe
is actually finite and so let me tell
you a little bit about what those are so
by the way i will try to put in the
notes
uh on the youtube video and on the blog
links to papers because basically like i
said i'm
telling you a lot of my most recent
research papers so i'll try to link to
mine and other people's that are
relevant here
so the idea is that
in qft you have this picture where here
is space
okay and here's some region
r and there's some boundary to that
region a so obviously really space is
three-dimensional
drawing a two-dimensional but the whole
thing uh this is you get it
right this is some region of space that
is three-dimensional as a
two-dimensional boundary that has an
area to it
and we could actually say something
about
the number of degrees of freedom inside
the region
r the answer is infinity in quantum
field theory but how do we know
how would we know uh you could just say
well i know it's a quantum field theory
okay but
that's cheating a little bit what is
another way of characterizing
why it must be true in quantum field
theory there are infinite number of
degrees of freedom
in there but one answer is the entropy
the entanglement entropy remember we
said that in quantum mechanics there's a
definition of entropy that came to us
from von neumann
that says when you have two qubits and
they're entangled each one of them has
an entropy if you have two qubits that
are unentangled their entropies are zero
so in quantum field theory there are
degrees of freedom
inside the region degrees of freedom
outside and they will be entangled
with each other in general so the
entropy of that
region r you can calculate it and the
answer is infinity
in quantum field theory okay well there
you go what are you going to say
um so there must be an infinite number
of degrees of freedom inside otherwise
you couldn't possibly get
an infinite entropy but
now you remember now wait a minute this
is quantum field theory in quantum field
theory
as we currently understand it says
ignore gravity
or to be a little bit more precise it
says you're allowed to put gravity
in but only weak field tiny amounts of
gravity you know the kind of gravity
when we talked about effective field
theories we noticed that
you could have an effective field theory
of quantum gravity as long as the
gravitational field is weak
it just acts like any other quantum
field but what about when gravity gets
strong
right we know that when gravity gets
strong you could put a black hole
in that region right and for a black
hole
beckenstein and hawking whose initials
are also the same as the initials of
black hole helpfully enough
beckenstein and hawking found out that
the entropy of a black hole
is the area divided by four in plank
units so
lp squared okay and that is
finite so
if you try to actually put stuff into
this region so you can start with a you
know
a region of space in the vacuum nothing
in there it's
the lowest energy state it can have you
put stuff in it more and more mass more
and more energy
what you'll find is that there's only so
much stuff
you can possibly put in there and
remember conceptually like we think of
you know taking
a brick or whatever and moving it into
that region
but what we're really doing in the
quantum field theory language is taking
a quantum field excitation
in the region that was in its vacuum
state its lowest energy state
and we're exciting it okay so the degree
of freedom was already there
the process of moving a brick is not in
quantum field theory
moving degrees of freedom it's turning
off some degrees of freedom and turning
on
other ones so we're turning on degrees
of freedom inside this region
and that's us a process that can only go
so far
okay you can only do that until you make
a black hole
so effectively there aren't an infinite
number of degrees of freedom
in the region you might have said you
might have had a description of the
region in terms of quantum field theory
that seemed to allow you to have an
infinite number of degrees of freedom
but that description breaks down once
you're making a black hole
and black holes we think represent the
maximum amount of entropy
that you can fit in a region and that
entropy is finite
so it turns out that if you have a
maximum entropy system
for max entropy systems
there is a relationship between the
number of degrees of freedom
and the entropy in other words given the
number of degrees of freedom which is
another way of saying
given the dimensionality of hilbert
space associated with that region
we want to entangle as much as many of
them with the outside world as we can
but there's only a certain number of
them
so the more entropy we want to get the
more we entangle it and there's an upper
limit
and the way the upper limit works is
that the dimensionality of the hilbert
space
uh is equal to i should say
approximately equal to there's some
fiddle factors in here but
e to the power of the entropy
of that region okay um so
the entropy of a black hole is already
big this is saying that the number of
degrees of freedom the dimensionality of
hilbert space rather
is e to that number which is a very very
big number okay
but it's still finite it's still less
than infinity and so
this philosophy leads us to conclude
that when you have a theory with gravity
quantum field theory breaks down
in a subtle non-local way it breaks down
at super-duper high energies we also
think separately
because otherwise you get infinities you
don't know how to deal with we think
that if you have two particles colliding
with a mutual
with a relevant relative energy greater
than the planck scale
then quantum gravity might be important
and that's a local
violation that's a violation of the
local quantum field theory that you
might hope to construct for gravity
this is a more spread out violation
of the rules of quantum field theory and
it's sort of the beginning of a hint of
what we call the holographic principle
right which is another violation of
locality once gravity comes into the
game so we're not going to worry about
that in any detailed way today
all we're going to do is say look at the
end of the day
since we do care about gravity we don't
need to worry about the complication
that helper space seems to be infinite
dimensional in quantum field theory
because that's probably not
true most of those infinite number of
dimensions of hilbert space
are inaccessible are not really there in
a theory where gravity is turned on and
you can make black holes black holes
provide a new kind of cutoff
on the dimensionality of hilbert's face
and make it finite
so let's work in an approximation where
it might be real so work in a in a
scheme where from the start
the dimensionality of hilbert space is
finite okay we're not going to try to
make it finite or pretend that it's
infinite so
think discrete
degrees of freedom and i don't mean by
that
you know they're on or they're off i
just mean there's a discrete number of
them there's a countable number of them
there's a finite number
this one this one this one this one
every think of it think of it
maybe maybe very roughly as a qubit
so when i say degree of freedom think of
just a spin something like that not
not a literal particle spinning but one
little two-dimensional
bit of hilbert's face that we're going
to build everything else up out of
and we're imagining that there are a
finite number of them
so then space once you
once you have a finite number of degrees
of freedom your
the best you can do is approximately get
back space
right because space the way we think of
it in general relativity or in quantum
field theory
is a continuum there's an infinite
number of points in space
but we're saying we're trying to
approximate it model it in a finite
dimensional hilbert space so it will
necessarily be an approximation
at that level so space in this picture
becomes some kind of network
okay or lattice it becomes some kind of
finite number of degrees of freedom
interacting in some way now again
we know from other investigations of
quantum gravity remember we talked about
ads cft and so forth
this is not going to work in all
circumstances but let's start small and
see if we can uh
figure out the basics and then we'll try
to get more complicated
so what we envision is a picture that
looks kind of like this
there are some nodes to our network and
these are our qubits or degrees of
freedom
or whatever and they're interacting so
there's little lines between them
designating when they can interact which
degrees of freedom interact with which
other ones because we want not only for
there to be a finite number of degrees
of freedom
but we want some notion of locality
right like what is allowed to interact
with
what else so here in this picture
this is going to be a picture that is
going to be valuable to us these dots
the nodes of the network think of them
as atoms
think of them as hilbert adams the name
i just now made up
so by that i mean little parts of
hilbert space
h i so a little tiny little hilbert
space by itself
such that the big hilbert space the
whole helper space for the universe that
we care about
is what we call it the product the
tensor product technically
of h1 oops let me get this right
so a tensor product is a particular way
of multiplying together vector spaces
you don't need to worry about the
details
um but the symbol is a time sign with a
circle around it
so this is h1 times h2
times h3 times etcetera
so each dot here is h1 or h2 or h3
and each line represent a possible
interaction
between those degrees of freedom okay
that's the picture we're going to have
in mind here and we want
the interactions to be local that is to
say if this
let me turn on my little flashlight yes
if this
hilbert adam is interacting with this
one that's okay
but this one does not directly interact
with this one over here
they interact indirectly through a chain
or something like that that's okay
but it's a it's an absence of i think we
called it dynamical
non-locality back when we were talking
about you know spooky action at a
distance
uh there's measurement on locality in
quantum mechanics if two things are
entangled they can be far away you
measure one
and it tells us something about the
other but there's no dynamical
non-locality in the hamiltonian in the
classical laws of physics from which we
derive our quantum mechanical equations
of motion
uh there's no direct non-locality it's
written as an integral over space
that's the form that the hamiltonian has
so the way that that translates into
this more discreet language
is that there are nearest neighbors that
we will find
uh and they can interact with each other
and you cannot interact with things far
away
so this particular way of writing
hilbert space
is what we're going to call a local
decomposition of hilbert space
and you might be worried a little bit
now because
we started by saying well there's just
one big hilbert space and one big
hamiltonian some energy eigenvalues
and now i'm saying well there are these
hilbert atoms these tinier hilbert
spaces
and there's a local decomposition there
and so did i cheat
by putting that in there the answer is
no because we're not saying that there
is such a local decomposition we are
asking whether or not there is a local
decomposition so
you give me the list of all the energy
eigenvalues and it's my job to say oh
okay
given those energy eigenvalues i can
decompose hilbert's space into a product
of these tinier hilbert spaces these
subsystems
that roughly corresponds to point
correspond to points in space
with the property that in that
decomposition the hamiltonian looks
local the hamiltonian only has
interactions between what we now call
nearby
degrees of freedom and not interactions
far away okay
uh and so people have asked this
question can you go from
a list of energy eigenvalues to a local
decomposition and the answer is here's
the answer
this is a paper written by some students
at
uh stanford kotler if i'm remembering
their names correctly pennington
and renard and i remember this paper
very well
it's just 2017 because i really wanted
to write this paper we were thinking
very
similar lines but they totally scooped
us on this one and so they asked this
question they said can you get a local
decomposition
that is fixed just by the spectrum the
spectrum is the name of the list of
energy eigenvalues of the hamiltonian
and the answer is most
hamiltonians h little hack on it means
it's a quantum mechanical operator okay
so this is a hamiltonian most
hamiltonians
have no local decomposition
so if you just give me some randomly
generated list of energy eigenvalues and
say what kind of spatial structure does
that
correspond to the generic answer is none
at all
there's no emergent space from that
there are certain special ones
that do and you know they do because i
could work the other way around right
that's usually what people do usually
you say okay i have a lattice
square lattice or triangular lattice or
whatever i have some degrees of freedom
i'm going to give them local
interactions
and then i do the hard work of finding
out what the energy eigenvalues are for
the whole system
okay that's a very standard physics
homework problem to do
here we're asking about the reverse
engineering problem given all the energy
eigenvalues can you figure out
how to divide the system into these
local subsystems
so they said the answer is uh usually no
usually there isn't any but when there
is
so when there is a way of going from a
list of energy eigenvalues to a
particular
graph of this form it is almost unique
and i emphasize almost not because it's
important or even because i will explain
it
but because i want to be technically
correct so there's some you know clearly
you can like reorder
let me just exchange the labels on
hilbert spaces
atoms that doesn't really make any
difference there's some other more
subtle
complications i mean there's a there's
one very obvious worry about this which
is ads cft
right because ads cft has two different
sort of classical
limits and so there's very there's
that's but you know there's only two of
them there's not
an infinite number of them the point is
that to a good approximation with some
little footnotes with some little
caveats
cutler it all showed that given
uh a hamiltonian expressed it's in a
state as a list of energy eigenvalues
you can figure out
if there is a local decomposition and
when there is you can figure out what
that decomposition is so in principle
and practice it might be very hard
but in principle you can see what kind
of space can emerge
so in for example you can figure out the
geometry of space the tap sorry
it's exactly wrong you cannot figure out
the geometry of space because this is
just topological information how the
things connect together you cannot
say how far away they are right but what
i was trying to say you can figure out
the topology of space
is it does it go on forever is it uh you
know closed in on itself in a taurus or
something like that
and most importantly you can figure out
the dimensionality of space
so i drew sort of a two-dimensional
network here but you can figure out
from the sort of network properties this
is does this network correspond to a
three-dimensional space a
four-dimensional space a
five-dimensional space etc
so there will be certain kinds of
hamiltonians that given enough brain
power and computational capacity you
could figure out oh yes
that is physics with local interactions
in a three-dimensional space okay
in this perspective you know unlike
string theory or extra-dimensional
theories you know we talked about
kalutsa klein theories way back when we
talked about space we talked about x-ray
dimensions and shrinking them right
here we're not purporting to offer an
answer to why
space has three dimensions we're just
saying it does and if it does you can
find that out by looking at the
eigenvalues of the hamiltonian
okay so that's good so that is you can
figure out the topology of space
dimensionality there's not really that
much else you can figure out but still
that's pretty good
so it's an example this is a great
paradigm for this this program of
starting with very very minimal data and
seeing how the real world can emerge
it's just the existence of space so it's
not very far
in constructing the world that we know
about but it's a good start okay
so what what so the program that we that
we've outlined here
is from the hamiltonian you get some
energy eigenvalues
and then you get a local decomposition
of hilbert's base
so this graph you know this graph really
represents hilbert space
not space but what we're saying is you
can write hilbert space in such a way
that different parts of it correspond
roughly speaking to different parts of
space
just like in quantum field theory once
you're given space
i can divide it up into little regions
and each one of those have their own
hilbert space and the whole thing is the
product of all of them
so it's a very it's just again reverse
engineering kind of
perspective what about the geometry
so geometry is a little bit more because
all we're given here is you know this
point
here interacts with that point and that
point
if you say well okay how far away are
they how much curvature is
if i took a vector and i parallel
transported it how would it change like
none of those words have any meaning yet
in this framework that we've given you
so
can we give them meaning um you know we
discussed
in the when we talked about geometry and
we talked about general relativity in
particular
you know we define geometry by the
riemann tensor
and parallel transporting vectors but we
noted that the particular way that
geometry shows up in general relativity
is really taking the metric as the
fundamental thing the metric is the
thing that gives us the length of
curves okay so metric
which is the length of curves
gives us the whole geometry if you have
some
space and on every single curve you
could tell me what the length of that
curve is
i could figure out the entire geometry
right that's one of the lessons that we
learned
so how do we get a notion of length in
this from this
hamiltonian well now what we're going to
do is
say you know look at
the ground state
psi zero the state of minimum energy and
this is work that i did with charles
tau and spiro's mycolocus
on space from hilbert's face it's a cool
name right i mean you got once you come
up with that name you gotta write the
papers which is obvious
so you look at the ground state um
remember
the ground state when we start we start
way up here
in uh stating what we mean by mad dog of
readiness
the ground state is just the state of
lowe's energy it's the state
with energy eigenvalue zero no energy
okay so there's nothing more to say
about it than that but now
we've emerged at least this sort of
lattice
network structure and so we can say
in this local decomposition what does
the ground state
wave function look like and again you
could solve that in principle it's a
solvable
problem it might be hard very very hard
hello
shout out to all you condensed matter
physicists out there it could be very
very hard
but it's doable in principle
and then you look at it on the graph and
what you'll notice is so
usually
um so by usually what i mean is
uh let's let's uh cut and paste this
this little piece to here
because we need it again
duplicate good um
usually you start when you do physics
with a notion of what you mean by
distance right i mean you know what the
distance is you're
when you have a like a lattice of
electrons or atoms or something like
that you can just take out your ruler
and figure how far
far apart they are and then what you
find
in the ground state of a system with
local interactions
is that there's there's a relationship
between the distance between different
parts of the system and how entangled
they are
okay so usually let's write that down
here
usually in local systems there's a
relationship that looks like
as the distance gets larger
the entanglement
gets smaller so you have something like
this
okay and the details will depend on the
system in various important ways that
we're not going to worry about now
so what it's telling you is you know you
don't have
distance built in in this perspective
it's purely quantum mechanical from the
start
so what you do have is this
decomposition that's what color it all
told us how to get
you have the state you can write in this
way and then you can look at
subsystems and calculate how entangled
they are calculate their
entropy and things like that there's
other things you can calculate the
mutual information
and so on but there's a number of ways
to characterize the entanglement between
different parts
and so if you know
that the answer you want to get has the
property
that things that are close together are
highly entangled and things that are far
away are not very entangled
i need to pause here because when i say
things
i don't mean this is a universal rule
remember we talked about alice and bob
and spooky action at a distance if i
have two electrons that are entangled
i can move them as far apart as i want
and their entanglement does not change
there is no
general rule relating entanglement to
distance what we're saying here
is in the vacuum state the ground state
the entanglement of the degrees of
freedom that are in their ground state
follows this kind of rule the particles
are excitations above the ground state
so they don't follow this rule at all
okay so there's no
general relationship between
entanglement and distance but in the
ground state degrees of freedom there
are
so if you know that's what you want to
get what you're going to do is just say
well maybe i can go the other way around
i don't have a primitive notion of
distance
but i have a primitive notion of
entanglement so maybe i can just
define entanglement
being related to distance
in that way so i'm going to draw the
same graph as i just drew
except that the independent variable
used to be distance and the dependent
variable entanglement now
it's a monotonic uh relationship so why
can't i just invert it
i in other words positing this is an
assumption this is not something i'm
deriving i'm guessing this is true and
then we're going to ask whether it works
okay so what we're guessing is that you
can measure the entanglement and what
we're guessing is the amount of distance
you have between two points can be
thought of as
inversely related to the entanglement
and that defines a geometry on our graph
so
color had all got a topology they got
the dimensionality and this local
decomposition
this extra little piece of information
that comes from the quantum state
not just from the hamiltonian it's
implicit in the hamiltonian because
hamiltonian defines the quantum state
it's the ground state
but it's this feature of the quantum
state that defines the geometry okay
and again it's just a hypothesis you're
saying well maybe this is true let's see
what happens
let's see what happens let's do that so
that's true for the vacuum state that's
that's the thing you're
guessing is true and we're not done
guessing yet we're not done making
assumptions the
let me let me sort of give away the
final answer here um
you can go pretty far in deriving
emergent space
from a program like this but
only by making a bunch of assumptions
and all these assumptions may or may not
be true it's not like their assumptions
which were
we're clueless about their assumptions
which we have not proven
are true okay so in our most recent
paper we said
here are the list of things you would
like to prove to make a program like
this work out it's long and we're not
very far yet
uh but that's the state of the game we
know all these assumptions seem
perfectly reasonable
we just haven't shown that they're true
yet okay so one assumption is this
distance entanglement relationship
here's another one is going to come up
soon so now
deform space a little bit so perturb you
might say
perturbation theory
in other words we start with the ground
state
the state of zero energy so now put some
energy in there look at another state
slightly excited slightly more energetic
than the ground state
and again we're going to use what we
know is true in the real world and then
ask what are the properties that our
emergent
world has to have to map onto that so
you imagine that you know this is the
emergent space that you get
from some number of degrees of freedom
that are interacting in some way
and you have some region and it has an
entropy and an area okay
and it will follow it will be the case
that in the ground state
the entropy is proportional to the area
that is again not true in general
the area of the boundary of the region
this is not a general rule
for quantum mechanical states this is a
rule for ground
states of systems with local
interactions okay
lowest energy states of systems which
have a local decomposition
have the feature that the entropy of a
region is proportional to the boundary
and you know why
it's because because the interactions
are local let me make this
colored let me expand this a little bit
because the interactions are local
there's strong entanglement right across
the boundary
and very little entanglement some but
very little very very far away
right so almost all the entropy comes
from degrees of freedom that are right
next to each other on the boundary
and how many of them are there while
it's proportional to the area of the
boundary so the entropy is going to be
proportional to the area that's not
at all surprising here's what's a little
bit surprising we can say
okay this is something we know to be
true
in psi zero the ground state in the
ground state entropy
of a region is proportional to its area
to the area of the boundary
let's imagine a new state
psi which is psi 0 plus delta psi so
we're going to perturb it a little bit
we're going to
add some energy we can't subtract any
energy because we're already in the
ground state
we know that in the real world if you
started with the vacuum and you put some
energy in there and you have gravity
then einstein tells us that that gravity
is going to deform the curvature it's
going to it's going to
bend the geometry of space so we're
going to go to something like this
right where there's degrees of freedom
that are scattered and their geometry is
now a little bit different
okay so that's a little dip and i can
draw a region where that dip
is because i put the energy there it has
a new energy
call it s prime call that psi prime call
that a prime
and what is the relationship going to be
between entropy and area
now well it should also for the same
reason
it should also be proportional to the
area because it's still true that the
interactions are local we only deform by
a little bit okay
so it was ted jacobson who came up with
this brilliant idea
and he came up with the idea in 1995
and then revisited it 20 years later
2015.
and it is what is the precursor to what
is now called entropic gravity
the name and tropic gravity was
popularized by eric verlinde
who did a different version of it but
it's a similar idea to what jacobson had
and the idea is what jacobsen said is
well if area is if entropy is
proportional to area
four systems in their ground state and
we
also know that in systems with gravity
the entropy of a black hole is
proportional to its area
okay if we know those two things maybe
this is a more
general universal law in other words
maybe
in theories with gravity if you change
the area of a region a little bit by
putting some energy in there and
changing the geometry of space
a little bit maybe that corresponds to
an exactly proportional change in the
entropy
so in other words maybe entropy
continues to be proportional to area
even when you're not in the ground state
it's the ground state where we know it's
true
and in other states in non-gravitational
theories look if i just have a real
lattice like i put a bunch of atoms
on a checkerboard okay and i let them
entangle with each other
and i measure the entanglement of a
subset it will be proportional to the
area when everything is in its ground
state but then i excite them
i can get rid of all that entropy i can
like break all the entanglement
and the area doesn't change right so
there's no necessary relationship
between entropy and area
in theories without gravity what
jacobsen says
is maybe in theories with gravity
when i try to change the entropy inside
a region
like by making more energetic right by
adding by exciting some of the degrees
of freedom or something like that
the geometry of space bends to
compensate
so this is jacobson's replacement
for einstein's equation you know
einstein's equation is a relationship
between energy
and the curvature of space-time jacobson
says instead of that
what he calls the einstein equation of
state is a relationship between
entropy and area of a region and he says
that gravity works to compensate
so that the entropy in a region is
always proportional to the area of its
boundary
not true in general but jacobson is
hypothesizing it for theories with
gravity
and then what he shows using math and
using some intuition and some magic
is that this area this decrement of area
can be related to
the left-hand side of einstein's
equation
remember einstein's equation r mu nu
minus one half r g mu nu equals eight pi
g
team you do we talked about this in the
space time uh knowing the gravity
uh biggest ideas video okay didn't go
into details this is a four by four
matrix that characterizes certain
properties of the curvature of
space-time this
this thing i just wrote down is called
the einstein tensor
and jacobson shows that in certain
limits with certain uh rules of the game
imposed this is characterizing the
changing area
of an area when you perturb the state a
little bit
and then he shows that the change in
entropy remember entropy had this way
back from
carnot and clausius entropy had this
relationship to heat
and temperature and energy back from the
good old days of thermodynamics
and so he shows that it is proportional
to the
energy momentum tensor and of course so
i can write proportionality here he
can't derive newton's constant of
gravity at least not yet
but in other words what he's saying is
this
hypothesis here of a relationship
between the change of area and the
change of entropy
leads in the bulk to einstein's equation
for gravity so what we're saying if you
follow all these rules and you believe
all the assumptions we're making
is that uh starting from
nothing but a hilbert space and a
hamiltonian
if the hamiltonian has the features that
there is a local decomposition
maybe it doesn't but maybe it does and
if it does let's pick it
in that local decomposition if we can
relate geometry to distance or
entanglement rather to distance and
derive the geometry that way
and if the entropy of a region given
that definition of uh
geometry is proportional to the change
in area when you perturb away from the
ground state
then not only do you get space emerging
but that emergent space very naturally
has a curve geometry
okay there's no reason why you should
prefer a flat geometry to that space
that is emerging if it depends on the
amount of entanglement and you change
the state the entanglement will change
of course the geometry that emerges is
going to change
and jackson argues that that dynamic
uh flexible space spatial geometry
gives us gravity in the way that we know
and love
now we there's a lot of steps here that
are being left out but
i i think of it more i think of it less
as a derivation of
gravity from quantum mechanics as a
consistency argument
that the idea that space-time obeying
einstein's equation emerges from the
wave function the way we want it
to is perfectly reasonable that's what i
think you should conclude from this not
that we know how to do it not that it
does work that way
you notice i didn't use any words like
strings or loops or anything
like that okay because i wasn't
quantizing a thing
we were taking the point of view from
the start that
gravity is quantum mechanical because
the universe is quantum mechanical so
the starting point should be a wave
function in hilbert space and we're
asking where do you go
from that how could you emerge the world
we see and the first thing you might
want to emerge is space-time and it
seems to have the right
properties okay we'll see whether or not
this continues
to go i'm very slow so i'm writing
papers so
it moves very very slowly my
collaborators are faster than i am but
still
i hold them back um there's still a lot
we want even if all of that works
even if we know even though we are
convinced that we've solved quantum
gravity right
which we're not but even if we were we
wouldn't be anywhere near done
because we know that there's stuff in
the world i mean here we have the energy
momentum
of the stuff team you knew and it's
really related to the
entropy but that's all you know we
didn't say what form the stuff took
there was no talk of quarks or leptons
or even you know
quantum fields in what we were talking
about
we use the fact that we know we want the
world to be described by a quantum field
to make
guesses about what we want the
hamiltonian to look like but we didn't
show how they emerged so that's the next
step so next
comes uh stuff
let's not be too hoity-toity about it
but you know stuff
is quantum fields
and not only quantum fields but you can
go further than that to
macroscopic objects right
we have a quantum field theory the
macroscopic world
we have quantum field theory it's a
microcosm but it's a kind
of quantum field theory as we talked
about when we talked about atoms and so
forth
it's a kind of kind of quantum field
theory that lets us construct atoms and
and molecules and stuff and you know
objects and things like that
so that's the kind of quantum field
theory we want
and so can we get that out of here and
so
there's a lot of work to be done we're
sort of going to skip a step i want to
tell you one more little thing
that we have established or argued along
these lines but a lot of the very basic
stuff like
why is there lorenzen variance you know
why is there locality these are
questions we don't yet know
the answer to and that's what we're
working on and one of the most basic
questions you can answer or you can ask
in those veins is
how do you divide the world
into subsystems
or for quantum mechanical decoherence
purposes the important thing is
system systems and the environment right
so we made the claim long ago that uh
you know schroedinger's cat in the real
world
the wave function the universe had
branched long before anyone opened the
box because the cat is interacting with
its environment and becoming entangled
with it
and that's the process of decoherence
and it's crucially important for
understanding why the universe looks
approximately classical right we talked
about hyperion as an example of that
recently so one of the things you'd like
to get emergent out of the hamiltonian
is
why are there systems and environments
and why do the systems
kind of look quasi classical so in fact
that's going to be
the criterion we're going to use so we
have been when we talk about the
emergence of space and gravity
the real rule that we that we cared
about the the guide guiding principle
that kept us on track was we want things
to be local
right we want there to be some locality
in the laws of physics and then jacobson
brought in this relationship between
entropy and area which is also related
now we're going to use a different
guiding principle which is
classicality so we want
to be able to say that the classical
that
out of our quantum theory there emerges
not only space and stuff
but that space and stuff behaves
classically
right in some approximation in some
regime
um there's no rule that says it has to
right there's no rule that says just
because i write down a hamiltonian for a
quantum theory there has to be some
classical limit of it
so we can play this game just like we
played with space itself and we can ask
uh under what circumstances can we have
classical behavior by which we mean you
know so here's what we mean
um here's there's here's one of the
problems is
that the definition of classicality is
different because classical physics has
many different aspects to it
okay it's different than quantum physics
but it's different in more than one way
so you might mean different things by
classicality here's a thing
that uh oh i forgot i forgot to say one
thing
how to divide into subsystems this this
topic
how to divide things into subsystems um
has a name in the in philosophy it is
called
myriology
muriology so that is not a type o uh
it's not supposed to be metrology or
meteorology
myriology is the study of the
relationship between
holes and parts so what we're doing here
is quantum
meriology that's what we're doing um and
what i mean by classicality i was going
to say
is that there's actually two things that
i that i'm going to care about
um so therefore let me move this over a
little bit so i can tell you what my two
things are
but imagine that i have some
wave packet okay here's space here's
time
and i have some electron or something
like that or not electron electrons are
too small so they're almost never
classical
i have a baseball or have a basketball
and to celebrate the nba successfully uh
coming back to life
here is the wave function of the center
mass of my basketball
and i want it when i you know shoot
toward the basket i wanted to follow a
classical trajectory
although it would be kind of cool if
quantum mechanical effects were
important in basketball
they're not so i want you know here's
the classical trajectory
let's say and what i want is for the
wave function of the basketball to do
two things one
i want it to remain peaked
so the fact that the if there is a peak
to the wave function the wave function
is for zero almost everywhere and then a
peak the fact that that
peak obeys the classical equations of
motion
so it moves along the classical path
rather than on some other path
that's aaron fest's theorem that's a
theorem we've already had that
we don't need to work for that okay but
we do have to work to
say number one that it remains peaked so
if the wave function just spreads out
all over the place
then the fact that the center of the
wave function follows the classical
trajectory is meaningless it's not
of no help to us okay we need that wave
function to remain peaked
and number two this is a more subtle
thing that people forget about
we need to remain unentangled
with the environment
so imagine that you know you shoot a
basketball and its
center of its wave function goes toward
the basket but in fact it keeps becoming
entangled with the environment so much
that it splits
into a billion different basketballs all
moving in different directions in
different branches of the wave function
of the universe
that would be bad right i mean we think
that in reality that does happen but the
amplitude for that is really really
really tiny so
when i say remain unentangled i mean
that once you have a quasi-classical
configuration of your quantum system it
doesn't
continually become extra extra entangled
at an incredibly rapid rate
in other words if you have schrodinger's
cat and it's in a superposition of awake
and asleep
we know from decoherence that will
quickly become entangled so there's a
part that is a weak and a part that is
asleep
but it doesn't keep getting entangled it
becomes entangled in those two states
even though there's avogadro's number of
particles in the cat
you'd not get avogadro's number of
branches of the wave function okay
so you need these two different
properties and
there's a lot to say about how these
properties uh
what you need to have these properties
be emergent
but you can say it so basically uh this
is in this another paper i wrote with
ashmit singh
quantum muriology
asked me singh and i recently wrote and
in fact it's still being edited
well it's on the archive but we're
revising it now um
what we claim is that there's an
algorithm that is very similar in spirit
to the idea of going from the energy
eigenvalues to locality
here we're saying you go from energy
eigenvalues to a definition of the
classical
subsystem and then the environment out
there that it interacts
with and we say well guess what not all
hamiltonians
let you have a classical limit at all
okay the hamiltonian itself the list of
energy eigenvalues needs to have certain
special properties
and what do you have in those properties
so there's an
algorithm there's what we call the
quantum meriology algorithm
which says you give me a list of energy
eigenvalues
and i will divide up the quantum system
into system and environment or subsystem
a and subsystem b
okay that's what the algorithm does and
just like the locality algorithm
it's not necessarily practical it might
take a very long number of steps i
wouldn't recommend putting it on your
laptop if you wanted to use it for
anything
but in principle you could do it you
basically sift through all the
possibilities
and you minimize certain functions you
can define
okay and what's really nice about it i
think
this is this is something you know the
finding the algorithm and showing you
know
the sort of robust features was the most
important thing but
we think maybe we found something
interesting along the way
if you think back um when we were
talking about space
so when we talked about the in the video
on
space you know space is space and you
might think it doesn't need a long video
to talk about space but
space is important because you know in
classical mechanics
i can expand this right now so
classically
classical newtonian mechanics right has
position
and momentum as variables and one of the
points we made when we talked about
space is that
in the formalism of hamiltonian
mechanics
position and momentum are treated on
equal footing right it's not like one is
is more important newton did not treat
them on an equal footing he put
x on as the primary thing and then he
derived
p the momentum but hamilton in
hamilton's equation sort of a more
sophisticated high-powered souped-up
version of classical mechanics
there's no difference between x and p so
therefore it becomes a question
and this is what we talked about in the
uh space video
why don't we live in momentum space why
is there something called
space which is only half of phase space
uh
and that's where we think we live rather
than in momentum space and we
gestured toward the answer namely that
space is a set of variables in terms of
which interactions look local
right interactions are local in space
two billion balls bump into each other
they're at the same place not if they
have the same momentum or opposite
moment or anything like that
that's roughly speaking the answer but
here what ashmi and i found
was maybe a different maybe it's the
same answer but in a different
uh set of clothing in a different
disguise
we found that if you wanted to have a
classical limit
for a perfectly general hamiltonian and
you wanted to maintain these two
properties that the wave function
remains peaked
and it remains roughly unentangled
then the classical limit that you will
be able to get has a certain special
form the hamiltonian uh
will take the form something like
something like is doing a lot of work
here but
1 over 2 m squared p squared momentum
squared
plus some function of x
which we call the potential in other
words
momentum you could label these you know
we labeled them x and p for obvious
reasons but you know you could label
them whatever you want but
one of the variables there will need to
be a variable
uh that just appears quadratically in
the hamiltonian p
squared and then the other variable can
have all sorts of powers x squared x
cubed x the fourth whatever
but there has to be a distinction
between these two kinds of variables
if you want to get a classical limit
that obeys those those
these two criteria at all okay
so just like most hamiltonians won't
give you a local decomposition into
space
most hamiltonians won't give you
classical behavior either the
hamiltonians that do
kind of look like this have a difference
between position and momentum so that's
interesting it's saying that
you know classical mechanics by itself
has no distinction between x and p
but the kinds of classical mechanics
that can be emergent from quantum
mechanics
do maybe i don't know i'm not completely
confident this is like
a little bit too new this is a paper
that we sort of just finished and i need
to
become absolutely sure that this is
right but it's kind of you know
interesting i like it i'm we're thinking
about it this is the kind of thing that
you know
gets me up in the morning to work on
this stuff um
okay i think that's all i want to say
about the emergence of space and
subsystems and things like that
i know there's something that you're
questioning in the back of your mind
which we haven't talked about
which is time
can time be emergent so again
if you grew up in a special relativity
or general relativity kind of background
you think that space and time should be
considered together
and that's fine as far as gr or sr are
concerned but quantum mechanics is a
little bit different especially
um this mad dog i've already in program
because you start with
a wave function which is a function of
time
and it's an element of hilbert space
right
at any one time and there's an equation
saying how the wave function evolves
h psi equals i d by dt
psi and right there
there's time there it is in case you
missed it time
um it's there in a way that space is not
in the schrodinger equation which is the
fundamental equation of this approach
time and space do not come in on an
equal footing now that doesn't mean they
can't
be on an equal footing it means they're
not put in
on an equal footing okay so this
framework for doing quantum mechanical
theories is a hundred percent compatible
with relativity
it just means the fact that time and
space that there's a symmetry lorenzen
variance between time and space
has to be a feature of the hamiltonian
this is where if lorenzen variance is
real
uh it's hidden some hamiltonians will be
correspond to lorentz and variant
dynamics and some will not okay
so in that case you know not only is
space emergent but lorenz invariance is
also emergent
and here in this way of writing things
time is not emerging
time is right there it's fundamental i
mean the distinction we typically draw
is between things that are fundamental
and things that are emergent and if
anything is fundamental here it's time
it's there in the in the foundational
structural equation of the theory okay
so it's completely you know don't listen
to people who say
you know time is an illusion or time is
not real and physicists have shown this
and it's just an emergent phenomenon
maybe it is but there's absolutely no
guarantee our state of knowledge of time
and space is not anywhere close to being
good enough to say whether or not time
is emergent
so it could be here time is fundamental
if this equation is true
but there is an alternative and you're
thinking like what could the alternative
possibly be this is the schrodinger
equation how could you
get rid of that so the alternative is
a subset of the schrodinger equation
namely
h psi equals 0
right if if the schrodinger equation
seems to imply
that time is fundamental and the rate of
change of the state with time is given
by this equation
uh you can still have the schrodinger
equation be true
but time not be fundamental just by
saying that the rate of change of the
wave function is zero it's not changing
it's static
so h psi does equal i d by dt psi
but that also equals zero the wave
function is the wave function it's not
evolving with
time and in fact a version of this
equation
pops out very naturally in some
approaches to quantum gravity where it's
called the wheeler dewitt equation
we you know this is uh john wheeler who
invented the words black hole in
wormholes and was
hugh everett's speech d thesis advisor
and richard feynman's advisor and kip
thorne's advisor
and uh bryce dewitt who was you know uh
hugh everett's champion champion at the
everett interpretation but this equation
has nothing to do with the
interpretation it's just a quantum
gravity equation in a certain way of
doing things
and so that's great you know okay that's
that's good you have an equation there
but
if you were if you were a faint heart
you would look at that equation say well
i know this can't be right it's ruled
out by experiment because i have a clock
and the clock tells time and this
equation has no time evolution in it so
how can it possibly be right well the
way that it could potentially be right
is if time
is emergent surprise surprise right
there you go
how could that possibly work so the
strategy is
if time is emergent from an equation
like this is that you write hilbert
space
as a decomposition of the universe
the rest of the universe if you like
times
a clock so you take out
some of the hilbert space of quantum
gravity or whatever your theory is
and you say this is a subsystem it has
certain number of states and those
states correspond
to readings of a clock
okay and then you say that
the state of the universe psi that is
obeying this equation up here has the
following form
uh it has you know well let's sorry i
need a little bit more um
notation here let's say that the states
of the part of the hilbert space
corresponding to the universe
we're going to call lowercase psi n
and the states of the clock we're going
to call
c sub n it's t for clock there you go
okay so then if the whole wave function
takes the form
psi 1 times c1
plus psi 2 times c2
plus you're guessing how this is going
to go right
then when you
read the clock that's like saying you're
collapsing the wave function on
c sub n for some n and when the clock
reads a certain thing the rest of the
universe is doing a certain thing
so this is as if
psi is a function of
c which is just like it being a function
of time
and then time is emergent in yet other
words so in other words
time is emerging from entanglement
between
the universe and sub subsystem of the
universe which functions like a clock
and there's different rules of the game
for how that uh
can work and and stuff like that um
let me sort of put into pictures so it's
easier to understand what's
going on so uh in other words let's
let's think about ordinary time
evolution right
so here's time here's
space and
space has some stuff in it and there's a
wave function and let's call it
psi one okay and there's also a clock
and the clock reads you know i don't
know uh
noon and there's another
time which there's another clock and now
the clock reads one o'clock
and another time up here now the clock
reads
two o'clock and this is going to be psi
well i said psi one so this is side two
psi three okay
so this is an actual
evolution of psi over time right this is
a conventional story
right and what we're saying is whenever
you have a situation like this
i could create a new wave function not
this one which is evolving with time but
i could create a new wave function
that is not evolving with time capital
psi
and i could just define it to be psi
1 times this clock
which says noon plus psi
2 times this clock which says 1 pm
plus psi 3 times
this clock which says 2 pm et cetera
and this big sigh isn't evolving with
time i took
all of the moments of time and i added
them together and because the clock has
a different reading
and each one of them uh they're the
individual pieces are orthogonal to each
other so they don't just smush together
they remain they
they could they may they maintain some
sort of uh coherent identity all by
themselves
and so in this wave function it is as if
time has emerged because
the wave function of everything is a
superposition of different states the
universe could be in
at different times the wave function a
whole though is static
so time in this way of thinking is what
clocks read
now you would have to go back to say
well now
still why is this lorentz invariant why
is it
the time part of space how does that
relate to each other and of course those
are all good things to think about this
is why
physicist physics is not done yet we
haven't done all these questions yet but
it's very plausible i mean the problem
with this the puzzle
the worry is of course muriology
so you said you started this whole thing
by saying that hilbert space was the
universe
times the clock right
who said that who gave you that
decomposition of hilbert space where did
that come from
in fact uh andreas albrecht of uc davis
has written about this in what he calls
the clock ambiguity
literally is what it's called he says
i could re-write hilbert's face in some
different way of writing it and i could
get a clock that read a
completely different thing and dynamics
for the rest of the universe that were
completely different
and i would have a completely different
set of laws of physics so that's bad um
you know back here when we were doing
i don't know you remember it when we had
the good old schroedinger equation
we said the way to do myriad muriology
the way to divide
hilbert's face into subsystems made
really crucial use of the hamiltonian
that's all we could possibly use right
you know we had all these different
energy eigenvalues
but in this approach the hamiltonian is
irrelevant
the hamiltonian just picks out one state
which then doesn't evolve
so it doesn't mean anything to give me
the hamiltonian
just give me psi right i mean there's a
solution to this equation just give me
psi here it is here's here's your vector
and then
all sides are created equal right
because the hamiltonian doesn't do
anything to it it's not evolving there's
no energy eigenvalues it's just a vector
in hilbert space
so none of this mad dog program that we
did makes any sense
uh when h psi equals zero you have no
information to build on
at all so something has to give and we
think that we know
what gives or we think we have a way of
fixing this i mean basically what we
think is true
is that when you have equations like
this
that's really not all you have okay uh
people say this you know here's a
hamiltonian
here's how it acts on the wave function
and it annihilates the wave function we
say it equals zero
but there's also so secretly here's what
we think is true
secretly
when you have h psi equals zero
you also have secretly an equation
capital h
equals uh i forget what it's called um
little h minus
i d by d lambda
okay so you can i mean what does this
mean that there's some variable
uh that corresponds to something
happening in hilbert's space
and you can rewrite you know this is
just a definition right this
i didn't do any violence or anything
weird i just
i mean basically if if you were given
capital h i could just define
yeah define little h as capital h
plus i d by d lambda right okay
um no one's going to stop me from doing
that
but the point is when i say secretly
what i mean is that
the theory that you are defining
isn't just capital h it's also the
statement that there is a particular way
to write capital h as a particular
little h
minus i by d d by d lambda and then
h psi
acting on h psi equals h
psi minus i d by d
lambda of psi and that's supposed to
equal zero therefore little h
psi equals i d by d
lambda psi but that's just the
schrodinger equation
if i think of lambda as effectively
being emergent time
okay the hamiltonian is now a little bit
different
but this decomposition has to be fixed
has to be given has to be part of the
definition of
theory secretly right and so that that
is a little bit you know it makes a mad
dog ever ready a little bit sad
that you need that extra piece of
information to define what you're doing
but i think that the upshot is that in
reasonable theories of emergent space or
time you really are always starting with
some version of the schrodinger equation
or another so that's how you get the
program
off the ground now
or or maybe not right i mean this is all
you know stuff that is
not completely agreed on or understood
this is research level stuff this is not
usually what we're talking about here in
the biggest ideas video
but you've learned enough you've learned
a lot over the last few videos to catch
up and you know
understand what's going on here and it's
important you know
you know if it makes a difference
because even though
you get an equation like this there are
still details so if you start with
if you start with the regular old
schroedinger equation you know what it
is right
um i'm going to write it down you know
ordinary short of your equation
h psi equals i
d by dt psi i'm not always consistent
whether i write my ds as roman or
curly d's but that's okay
here is an immediate implication of this
without doing any work uh the t
goes from minus infinity to infinity
time never begins or ends according to
this equation
that i mean you could just solve it then
you can evolve you never had a
singularity this is a linear equation
you never worry about the big bang or
anything like that
it's an immediate conclusion if this is
the equation
and you're not in this weird subset
where h psi equals zero
then time is eternal full stop um
how to interpret that in space time is
it you know is there secretly a big bang
or something like that well
okay that's work that's again you know
stuff we don't understand but this much
we understand
this is this is something i once labeled
the quantum eternity theorem
which is kind of a joke because
because i can't spell eternity i guess
eternity theorem
because it's just too obvious to be
called a theorem it just
instantly follows from the schrodinger
equation that time goes from mice to me
to infinity
so but it's a reminder that there's a
lot we don't know
when it comes to quantum mechanics and
gravity and the big bang
and the emergence of space-time and all
of these things uh there's a lot of
low-hanging fruit remain to be picked
there's a lot of
questions that are very fundamental very
easy to ask to which we
don't yet know the answer so um i think
it's a lot of fun i think it's a great
thing to be thinking about these days
you know
our this is stuff that you could have
been asking in the 60s you know nothing
that i wrote down here
is uh newfangled stuff that we didn't
invent and you know maybe some things in
quantum information and entanglement but
roughly speaking this is the kind of
stuff you could have done a long time
ago but people didn't they were
interested in other things
so now we've improved our appreciation
for quantum mechanics and entanglement
and quantum information to the point
where
we're bringing new tools to bear on
these old problems
quantum gravity and so forth and i for
one am optimistic that we're going to
make
progress but uh hopefully we'll see so
in the future
if in fact time is real and not emergent
i shouldn't say that i'm not going to
stop there i was going to stop there on
a dramatic pause but
things that are emergent are still real
okay time is real
don't listen to anyone who says the time
is not real that's ramen